Video Nummer 157, Szene 4, Take 3
Einige von euch haben mich vermutlich
vor diesemRegal hier kennengelernt.
Denn angefangen hat Doktor Whatson,
wie bei so ziemlich jedemYouTuber, im Wohnzimmer.
Klar, damals war ichauch noch komplett alleine,
also habe ichmeine Wohnung zum Filmsetgemacht.
Drei Jahre undknapp 80.000 Abonnenten später
kam dann der nächste große Schritt.
Aus Doktor Whatson wurde eine GmbH,
aus der Ein-Mann-Band ein Team
und aus meinem Wohnzimmer dieses Studio,
das ihr wahrscheinlich alle kennt.
Der zentrale Baustein davon ist der blaue Hintergrund,
auf dem wir zum Thema passende Muster
oder auch Illustrationen einfügen können,
die für den typischen Look sorgen.
Aber, ob ihr es glaubtoder nicht,
hinter mir ist kein Greenscreen,
auch wenn das noch bis heute
viele von euch glauben.
Diese Wand existierttatsächlich,
so wie diese Requisiten, oder auch die Lampe.
Nichts davon ist digital.
Heute erklären wir euch endlich,
wie wirdas geschafft haben.
Aber auch, warum Greenscreens häufig so schlecht sind
und wodurch sie gerade von Hollywood ersetzt werden.
[Musik]
"They're on a green screen.
This entire roof is a green screen."
[lachend] "Look at that green screen!"
"They can change their background entirely
and be anywhere or everywhere at once."
"These sets are insane."
"What makes this revolutionary,
is that they can use a moving camera."
Greenscreens sind überall.
Schon längst nicht mehr nur in Hollywood,
sondern auch in Twitch-Streams
und sogar Zoom-Calls.
Überall, wo man Menschen und Dinge
in eineandere Welt transportiert,
kommt der Greenscreen zum Einsatz.
Wenn er gut gemacht ist, bleibt er unsichtbar,
manchmal fällt er aberauch extrem auf
und zerstört die Illusion.
Das Prinzip ist eigentlich recht simpel:
Wir wollen den Hintergrund einer Person
durch etwas anderes ersetzen.
Dafür müssen wir
diePerson vom Hintergrund trennen,
also quasi "ausschneiden".
Das kann man auf verschiedeneArten machen.
Unter anderem, indem man wortwörtlich
um die Person herum schneidet.
Und zwar Bild für Bild.
Das nennt sich Rotoskopie
und ist gerade für längere Szenen extrem mühselig.
24 Bilder pro Sekunde sind
bei einigen Minuten Material viele Bilder.
Deswegen kam ein Filmemacher
namens Lorenz Butler 1940 auf eine Idee.
Was, wenn man diePerson
nicht vor irgendeinem Hintergrund filmt,
sondern vor einer einfarbigen Wand?
So kann mandiese spezifische Farbe
quasi "herauslöschen"
und übrig bleibt alles andere,
nämlich unsere Personim Vordergrund.
Das war die Geburt des "Chroma Keying",
für die Butler 1941 einen VFX-Oscar gewann.
Damals ging das allerdings
noch ein bisschen anders.
Erstens war derheute typische Greenscreen
damals noch ein Bluescreen.
Die werden zwar auch heutenoch verwendet,
aber seltener.
Weil digitale Kameras
im grünen Bereich die höchste Auflösung haben
und Grün weit entfernt von typischen Hautfarben ist.
Außerdem arbeitete man damals
natürlich noch mit richtigem Zelluloidfilm.
Das machte den Prozess des Keyings komplizierter,
aber auch das Compositing,
also das Zusammenfügen mitneuen Hintergründen.
Was man damals noch
mit Chemie und Projektoren lösen musste,
geht im digitalen Zeitalter
mit Software undwenigen Klicks.
Man wählt einfach die genaue Farbe des Greenscreens aus
und schon radiertmir die Software
den Hintergrund komplett weg.
Geile Technik!
Aber wo ist denn da der Haken?
Wenn das so einfach und zugänglich ist,
warum sehen dann so viele Greenscreen-Szenen
immer noch so fake und einfach schlecht aus?
Das kann uns Marian erklären.
Er ist unser Kameramann, Chef der Postproduktion
und für das visuelle Konzept
von Doktor Whatson mitverantwortlich.
Und, Fun Fact, er ist auch der Editor dieses Videos.
Es gibt 3 Hauptprobleme,
warum Greenscreens so schwierig sind.
Erstens: die Interaktion mit der Umwelt.
Dadurch, dass wirdas Subjekt ausschneiden
und irgendwo neu reinsetzen
haben wir natürlichdiese ganze Interaktion
nicht, wie Licht, Schatten
oder auch Haare oder Kleidung, die im Wind wehen,
die Bewegung der Kamera im dreidimensionalen Raum.
All das fehlt entweder komplett,
oder muss aufwendig simuliert werden.
Und selbst dann passt esmanchmal nicht zu 100%
Und unser Gehirn ist zu gut darin,
Realität von Simulation zu unterscheiden
und wird dann deswegen aus der Illusion gerissen.
Das zweite Problem ist dann das Ausschneiden selbst.
Dass man das wirklich sauber hinbekommt.
Denn wenn wir dem Computer nur sagen,
alle grünen Pixel transparentzu machen
und alle anderen sichtbar
muss er in den semitransparentenTeilen entscheiden,
ob da genug Grün drin steckt,
um zum Hintergrund zu gehören
oder gerade noch nicht.
Da gibt es natürlich viele Slider
undEinstellungen für's Finetuning.
Aber häufig gehen trotzdemfeine Details verloren.
Man muss super viel Zeit reinstecken
und es wird auch eigentlich nur dann überzeugend,
wenn die Drehbedingungen perfekt waren.
Das dritte Problem entsteht auch insbesondere
unter suboptimalen Bedingungen.
Zum Beispiel, wenn der Greenscreen zu hell ist
oder derAbstand zu gering.
Dann wird immer auch
ein Teil des Lichts und der Farbe reflektiert.
Und dann haben wir etwas,
das wir "Spill" nennen.
"Spill" heißt ja übersetzt so viel wie "überlaufen".
In dem Fall ist das "Überlaufen"
ein Grünschleier in unerwünschten Bereichen,
Zum Beispiel in Hautfarben.
Das sieht einerseits sehrkränklich aus,
und es verstärkt das Problem,
dass der Computer falsche Pixel als Greenscreen erkennt.
All das sind Probleme,
weswegen gerade in Amateur-Produktionen
Greenscreens häufig sehr schlecht aussehen.
Aber es ist sogar so,
dass bei krassen Hollywoodproduktionen,
wie zum Beispiel "Avengers" oder so,
Szenen vor Greenscreen gedreht wurden,
aber am Ende dochhändisch ausgeschnitten werden.
Weil es besser aussieht
und man mehr Kontrolle darüber hat.
Ok, alles gar nicht so einfach,
wie es auf dem Papier klingt.
Wie löst man denn jetztdiese Probleme?
Warum haben wir keinen Spill oder Kanten-Probleme,
während man trotzdem noch jedes Haar von mir erkennt?
Ich spann' euch noch eine Minute auf die Folter.
Denn es gibt ein paar geniale Alternativen zu Greenscreens,
die wir nicht verwenden,
über die ich aber trotzdem gerne sprechen möchte.
Zum Beispiel kann man dem PC beibringen,
das Subjekt anders zu erkennen.
Eine inzwischen relativ bekannteTechnik
basiert auf Gesichts-/Objekterkennung.
Hier benutzen Algorithmen
keine Farbwerte zumAusschneiden
sondern versuchen tatsächlichzu "verstehen"
welches Objekt sie ausschneiden sollen.
Manchmal wird hiersogar Machine Learning eingesetzt
– also "Künstliche Intelligenz", wenn man so will.
Die meisten von euch
kennen das wahrscheinlich von Videokonferenzen.
Fast jedes Programm, das man dafür nutzt,
besitzt die Möglichkeit,
den Hintergrund zu ersetzen oder unscharfzu machen.
Auch die künstliche Tiefenschärfe im Smartphone
wird oft so generiert.
All diese Technologien werden immer besser
und ich finde es mega krass,
das wir sowas inzwischen
in der Hosentasche herum tragen können.
Bis zur Kino-Qualität
dauert es trotzdem noch ein bisschen.
Eine für uns Filmschaffende besonders spannende Technik
geht quasi in die andere Richtung
und verzichtet komplett auf Software-Tricks.
Und zwar, indem sie den Greenscreen
durcheinen tatsächlichen "Screen" ersetzt.
Hier haben wir beides vereint:
Eine digitaleProjektionsfläche für virtuelle Umgebungen
und gleichzeitig einefotorealistische Interaktion
zwischen Subjekt und Umgebung.
Indirekte Beleuchtung, Reflektionen
und sogar komplizierte Refraktionen
funktionieren genauso,
wie man es am physischen Set erwartet.
Besonders bekannt wurde die Technik
durchdie Serie "The Mandalorian".
Nicht nur, dass wir
keine typischen Greenscreen-Probleme haben,
die Kamera ist außerdem
in Echtzeit mit der Engine verbunden,
die diese 3D-Umgebungengeneriert
So wird bei Kamerabewegungen
eine 100% realistische Tiefe simuliert.
Das ermöglicht Shots, die sonst viele Stunden
in der Postproduktion gekostet hätten.
This is the way.
Aber was ist denn jetzt
das Prinzip bei uns hier im Studio
Die virtuellen LED-Stages von The Mandalorian
konnten wir uns so gerade nicht leisten.
Auch habenwir keine Armada von Praktikanten im Keller,
die mich Bild für Bild rotoskopieren.
Aber wir haben eine andere Methode gefunden,
die uns vonden Grundzügen
wieder zurück zumAnfang,
dem Chroma Keying, bringt.
- Diese ganzen Probleme,
die wir angesprochen haben,
bestehen ja vor allem deswegen,
weil wir die Pixel vom Greenscreen
am Ende zu löschen
und durch was anderes zu ersetzen.
Unser Idee war deswegen:
wir umgehen das ganze einfach
indem wir beide Pixel behalten.
Also den Screen selber
und das, was wir darauf anwenden.
- Ok, aber was heißt das denn jetzt?
- Konkret heißt das:
Wir drehen dich vor dieser Wand,
die bewusst ineinem Blau-Grauton gestrichen ist.
Denn können wir ansprechen wie einen Bluescreen,
aber anstatt die Pixel zu löschen,
behalten wir sie
und können dich als ausgeschnittene Maske
zusätzlich nochmal darüber legen.
Das heißt, wir haben die Wand alsunterste Ebene
dann die Illustrationen, die wir einfügen wollen
und dich dann nochmal
als ausgeschnittener Cedricoben drüber.
Und der große Vorteil:
wenn wir keinen perfekten Key hinbekommen,
was durchaus vorkommt,
je nachdem, was du zum Beispiel trägst,
dann verlieren wir Details,
aber das ist nicht so schlimm.
Denn ein verlorenes Haar auf der einen Ebene
liegt immer noch auf der untersten Ebene,
quasi als Backup.
Das fällt nur dann auf,
wenn die Animation genau zwischen dieses Detail
und dem Hintergrundfällt.
Und so wie wir die Animationen gestalten,
ist das meist nicht der Fall.
Und auchder Spill ist ja komplett realistisch,
weil die digitale Umgebung
zu 99% die tatsächlicheUmgebung matcht.
Wenn du vor einer blauen Wand stehst,
erwartet man einen blauen Spill.
Im Gegensatz zu einem
unnatürlichen Greenscreen-Spill.
Ok, da habt ihr's!
Das ist also das "Geheimnis"
hinter der Doktor Whatson-Wand.
Es ist kein Greenscreen,
sondern quasi einBluescreen,
den wir ins Set integriert haben.
Ich hoffe, euch hat dieser kleine Blick
hinter dieKulissen gefallen.
Das war heute kein typisches DW-Thema,
aber es gab wiegesagt viele unter euch,
die die Funktionsweise unseres Studios interessiert hat.
Und wir bei TWENTYTWO sind ja alle Filmemacher*innen
und reden sowieso gerne über solche Dinge.
An dieserStelle auch noch mal danke an alle,
die an diesem Hintergrund beteiligt waren.
Insbesondere an meinen
ehemaligen Filmschul-Kommilitonen Mick,
der die ursprüngliche Idee hatte.
Wenn ihr mehr solcher Videos
über Film & Fernsehensehen wollt,
schreibt uns das gerne in die Kommentare.
Wir machen sowas wie gesagt immer sehr gerne.
Zum Beispiel haben wir überlegt,
einmal die Entstehung eines Doktor Whatson-Videos
im Detail dokumentieren
– von der ersten Ideebis zum Upload.
Wenn ihr das nicht verpassen wollt,
dann abonniertden Kanal.
Ansonsten, wie immer:
Bleibt neugierig, euer Cedric!
[Sci-fi noises]